now in this lesson we'll come back
differentiation and basic basic
integration okay
there's lots of it's not the twist and
turn all that kind of thing so I will
just start with the basics
here's that here's the question I'm
gonna post or stop a sign a mess then
we'll go through cosmos antennas as well
if this is y what's do you wanna do X
what is the derivative okay now you
remember right we made a big deal out of
the difference between this inverse
function right and this inverse relation
we've said these are not the same okay
there's a big difference between them
namely that this it Wiggles on forever
whereas this only exists in a certain
range right but we are going to use this
as a useful tool noting that it's only
true in a certain domain now what is the
domain again
sorry not domain certain range what's
the range up to punch it because it's
it's inclusive okay so I'm going to
consider this as this but only in this
domain okay so if I went outside it
would break but now that I've got that
we can actually do calculus with this
really easily because this is a very
very simple function right I can't quite
work out do i DX yet but I can work out
DX or dy because I've swapped my inputs
and outputs the whole idea in universe
right
so therefore what's it equal to what's
the derivative of sine it's just cause I
can't now I've got the X with you I in
all this work with integration okay
differentiation we've seen that DX of UI
even though it's different to just a
regular fraction in many ways you could
consider it as a normal fraction okay so
I can take this and I can take the
reciprocal right so I can get dy DX out
of this okay so so am I done
I kind of am right I have an expression
for dy DX okay but being we started with
a function of X and now my derivative is
a function of Y
that's a confusing okay later when we
look at motion particularly three
division will see this albeit actually
you differentiate with respect to one
variable and one you get is in terms of
another variable okay but for now I want
to go back to my original in terms of
X's okay so now you've got a few
different options right clearly there's
going to be some identities involved
okay
but I would suggest probably the most
direct path back to getting things in
terms of X's and Y's is this line okay
now is a it's in terms of sine Y which
is all noticed cause line right almost
okay so what can I do to get from here
back to something like this because
that's in terms of X's see that okay so
what I'm gonna remember is the
Pythagorean identity okay
namely sine squared theta cos square
theta is equal to you can see here since
I've got sides and causes my basic signs
of closeness my pieces I can just
rearrange this to get one in terms of
the other right now what I've got is
cause I want it in terms of sines so
let's change the subject so if I squared
is 1 so can I say this
is that a fair statement and the answer
is no not quite
it's half of a fair statement isn't it
okay because I can I can get to
legitimate solutions out of this right
so I really need to include that all
right so let's just hold on to that for
a sec you know this is all in terms of
theatres I've got in terms of wires
right so this is equal to 1 plus or
minus okay okay now sign why that's just
X right so that's plus or minus I'll
just pop that in the top square root of
1 minus x squared okay so here is
allegedly okay now stop and think for a
bit okay we're not used to this when we
differentiate a function we're used to
starting with something one thing and
ending with one thing right but here we
start with one thing and we ended with
two hmm now we can think about this two
ways we could think okay that's just
weird
right and how do we get rid of it as a
problem okay and you can get rid of as a
problem but alternatively you can think
well why is this okay it's usually a
different shape something that you don't
end up with this as a problem hmm what
do you think you Jesse
aha so we started with right looks like
this doesn't it so what's the part that
we usually interested in we're usually
interested in that part right but
because our actual starting point was
here which was the relation right it
keeps going like so I could drop the
more of it right but I'm just gonna
leave that part for now now can you see
what's the difference between these two
parts with regards to the derivative
okay if you've got this top section here
right it's an increasing function can
you see that it's always going on so
it's Grady should always be positive
right and when you compare it to the
other part that I've drawn
okay it's a decreasing function right
it's always decreasing but not just is
it decreasing it's decreasing at
precisely the same rate as this is
increasing right so in other words the
derivative up here so it's a why that's
the positive part okay so this is which
which one's the positive part the
denominator is always positive the case
of just depends on the numerator so this
is +1 on square root of 1 minus X square
okay this section down here that's the
other part that's the negative part so
do you see what's going on now we wanted
we placed the restriction on this right
so now we know which part we want okay
so this point here I would say and this
is actually a crucial part just like
whenever you eliminate a solution you
need to say why like cuz it's a tire
because it's a distance or whatever I
saved but for this term this range okay
to on to okay
why is it increasing function y of X is
increasing okay in other words its
derivative must be greater than zero
okay so that's my justification for
excluding one of the answers
okay there's a result yeah you mean can
I do this whole process without this
from here to here yes I suppose I put
the graph just so you have a picture in
your head and you can see why I'm saying
it increasing and therefore the
derivative must be positive but if you
were asked to show this result you
wouldn't need to I think the words are
sufficient it stands on two so you're
saying put me in here one on cause yeah
you can but you end up having the same
kind of issue in that you've got it it's
like well now you have to justify why
this is positive well only only in the
certain domain right if I go that side
that domain I'm in trouble but I'm gonna
make the same kind of argument okay I
think I see what you're getting at I
think you can I think you can I think
this is still better this is the reason
why I'm showing this one to you because
this gets a geometric payment from the
derivatives you see what I'm trying to
find right so I think that's a bit
hold on stop
isn't it is increasing me that's it I
mean that's usually when you think about
it right is this an increasing function
this context here right it's not just
going straight it's actually going to
something right I think it's the one and
you got to remember as well right that
this you can't I can't actually just lop
off the endpoints because I started with
these I can't just take away a part of
the the range because it's inconvenient
and then you'd still get you'd get an
undefined video it's still it's still
fit to my derivative it still fits
exactly my do it because you'll be
dividing by zero because you'll have one
or minus one here still works
despite justify this yeah okay how let
me get rid of them let me do this
this money is an increasing function ie
that is the dues
all right so the argument I was making
was I arrived at this point now I'm like
I've got two alternatives to my
derivative and it feels like there
should only be one so how do I justify
that we want to not be enough and the
answer is I look at the way I've
restricted this grant okay because it's
not really all of this it's just one
part of it okay and I noticed that it
has this characteristic it's increasing
so my derivative should be positive okay
so therefore you know what you have a
look at the alternative the alternative
is on this there is no value of x no
real value of x that you can insert into
here which will make that positive right
so that means it can't possibly be the
actual derivative that I'm looking for
so therefore I excluded I discount it as
a credible option because it would have
there are no values in this domain which
would make it make sense no I don't
think so
I mean I'm drawing the graph so that
this statement actually makes it usually
this series there usually because there
is not this is my standard type question
right the standard type question would
be please your function find the
derivative and you can go straight here
because we just shine it right but if
you had to prove it like if I'm telling
you why is this the case why isn't it
plus or minus I have to have to
demonstrate why right so that's why I'm
going through sort of an extended
process and you wouldn't really have to
do that into - okay last question
I suspect there is but I haven't thought
about it why do you give it a go let's
take on so much I'm interested so long
as you're doing the way let's do because
of us now because we already noted all
of the tricks that we needed for sine
inverse cos in this falls out quite
easily but it still has some interesting
photos that I want to notice okay now
this time by I heard your head last time
you don't mind this time how do i how do
I know it doesn't know it does it I
thought my kids hands over time they got
dragged along okay all right
is that fine am I missing anything thank
you what is the restriction okay know
what ah that is very helpful what for
the next step differentiate with respect
to okay and the derivative is okay so
what I absolutely want is the dig
respect to X okay now
do the thing with the guy on the stuff
right what do I do
okay so I'm going to use this identity
of the Pythagorean I didn't he write
what you can't just take one of them
right you've got to do this but okay be
happy with that so god I've got a nose
that range okay now I suppose in some
way that doesn't matter all that much
but I'm gonna write at the proper way
which is actually minus plus on the top
to take into account the fact that
that's maybe new okay one on the square
root of Matt close why I know what close
why is okay now I'm in the same point
that I was before
what do I do I know that cos inverse is
a decreasing function it's not this guy
it's it's this guy there abouts okay
so I can say this is dy/dx
but as Y is decreasing
I know that I'm gonna take the negative
value okay so that's why I can say these
three views now hold on a second now
looks suspicious doesn't this well not
so much suspicious that's familiar what
is that it's just that it's the yeah you
slap a minus sign on the roof for sine
inverse and you get the derivative of
positive which is which is hot on a
second of course that's what it is
because when you put these on top of
each other their gradients are opposite
right at this point you know you're
going down at this point let's pick the
middle right you're going down to get
gradient of minus 1 versus going up at a
grave of one okay and you're approaching
positive infinity and you're
appreciating negative feet at exactly
the same right okay so there's our
derivative
cos inverse okay all right you guys do
the tan in this one on your own